this was a battle of mvp candidates in
baltimore so you're telling me when you
get a quarterback and you develop an
offense around his talents and things
like that that he could be successful
man that's crazy but that's been the one
thing that i think nfl coaches have
finally warmed up to in recent years if
you're going to take the guy
based upon what he does in college
the more you can simulate at the next
level the offense that he was so
successful in sure the more likely he is
to be successful at the next level
they've finally gotten away from this
nonsense that you have to do something
different you gotta jam the guy into an
offense play like brady or rogers no
he's not that he's not the pocket
quarterback like that that's not what he
does so a good coach figures out an
offense that works out because they were
smart enough to go oh okay yes maybe
he's not going to be like the
quarterback that dissects you from the
pocket all the time which he's getting
very good at by the way but
they took advantage of it they went oh
man his running and some of that is next
level like we've never seen anybody like
this and they're going with that and i
just i give the ravens a ton of credit
for that uh and having that vision they
were two and two after four games yeah
they have won six in a row and the first
game in that winning streak came at
pittsburgh that crazy overtime game
where mason rudolph got knocked out on
his feet and marlon humphrey saved the
day by knocking the ball out of juju
smith schuster's possession in overtime
giving the ravens the opportunity to win
the game and then they barely beat the
bengals week six and it and at that
point that's when they found something
more the last four games i think have
been very impressive we talked earlier
about not peaking too soon hopefully for
the ravens standpoint they're not
peaking too soon but to go to seattle
and win by 14 beat the patriots by 17
not stepping a pothole against the
bengals blow them off the field last
week 49-13 and now
i'd say the most impressive win of the
year a texans team that was in first
place in the afc south that was in
position to shake up the top of the afc
if they had won yesterday in baltimore
and you've got deshawn watson who pulls
a rabbit out of the hat all the time
just shutting him down and blowing him
out i mean it was impressive and you
know the ravens team is going to keep
rolling they've got some difficult games
coming up they've got challenges at the
rams they've got the 49ers they have to
go to buffalo which won't be easy
schedule softens a little bit after that
with the jets and the browns but the
browns already beat them how did you say
that when the browns have come into your
building and beating you how can you say
it's an easy win to go to cleveland and
beat them no and then the steelers week
17 who would love nothing more if
they're out of it they would have
nothing more to go in there and screw
things up for the ravens sure well we've
seen the browns i mean they're not going
to be a pushover the browns have talent
i mean they dominated the steelers the
other night really i mean they dominated
them so they are dangerous and we've
seen when they play their best football
they can beat just about anybody here
you said it they beat the ravens the
ravens got their mojo going they're the
best team in football right now they're
playing an extremely high level they're
like you know they remind me you know
after that sunday night win against the
patriots they i feel like they're like
mike tyson in their prime right they're
bullies and once they start to get some
knockouts and going you just they like
they feed off it like okay we're coming
out for the knockout again this week and
i just feel like they're that way they
feed off of we're the big bad team on
the field i mean all right so so who's
there buster douglas yeah i don't know
no i did they get a hope they don't fall
into a trap and go over to tokyo and
party the whole time and not train okay
they can't fall into that trap and start
reading their press clippings if they
stay on though they will win the
majority of their games from here on out
i don't care who you put in front of
them but mike to run for 260 yards as an
offense on the houston texans that was
unbelievable and you know we'll stop
forget early in the game they missed the
field goal they had a fake field goal
they went 4-2 right and didn't get that
so their offense kick and butt
defense contained desean watson confused
their protection all game long and i
mean you know
they're number one in your power
rankings and i think you're right
they're the number one team in the sport
right now last year it was or last week
rather it was kind of by default that
they were number one yeah this this week
they were gonna put the standards yeah
to beat a playoff team a team that was
12-4 last year that was in first place
in the division so badly you got to be
number one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports